preacher you're really deep into the
boxing ring what are you talking about
man
did you see that like a thousand times i
did a thousand punches no but it
wouldn't do it ever considerably oh
really yes are you looking at doing it i
would totally do yes would you fight
like logan or jake yes yes which one
both of them i don't care at the same
time at the same time no i would menage
to i'll fight them
that's better than roommates i would be
way better than
no but uh yeah i would absolutely fight
him no but are you serious and you're
yeah i'm serious i'm pretty listen i've
already already fought uh bellator
fighters ufc fighters and just pro
fighters i've already fought them in the
gym it just hasn't been on tv and hey
let me tell you what isn't that
different about spot sparring it's way
different
but i still felt it i mean someone hit
me so hard in the stomach i hit that
kaepernick one time i was like black
lives matter
got to play it up
like i was praying i was like jesus play
hey man anyway so let's get back to
spawn i just like to pray in the middle
of punches but uh you know sometimes it
hurts and i realize i'm a comedian but
um i do really well you know i do really
well i've never been dropped i've never
had a black eye you know i do get beat
up and you're going to get beat up but i
do some beating up you know so is this
something you would like to pursue also
absolutely so why don't you make that
known well i i uh i just think what he's
doing right now yeah i'm doing it right
now hey guys i would love to i would
love to do a match but i i think i you
have your eye on somebody uh an opponent
that you do i don't think there's i
don't hate anybody you know you have to
hate somebody too you got to find
someone that you're like hey you want to
do a beef you know but this i wanted to
fight a comedian but all the comedians
want to do boxing and all the comedian
boxers that would fight me they've been
boxing for like 20 years i'm like i'm
not gonna box someone that clearly will
beat me up in boxing but like jake paul
and logan paul they're trash what about
joe rogan
joe rogan
uh i mean i'll totally fight him just
because he's joe rogan but joker's like
he's not gonna fight me he's too rich
he's a billionaire why would he come you
know what do you think he could beat him
do i think he beat him in the stand-up
fight yeah i think he's slow i think
he's a way better i think he kicks
harder than anyone but i think his kicks
are
i'm not trying to diss you joe but like
i feel like his kid i feel like he's
kind of slow and i feel like he's back
he's more he's he studied twice
so he's not really a heavy uh heavy on
boxers he's more heavy on leg kicks and
i think you think you can beat up my
daughter you know what no i don't think
i could i don't know i'm a black belt
she's a black belt yeah well i'm a black
man so uh you can't hit me because we're
in l.a and it's 2021. i'll scream i
really will
all right you don't want me to do it
okay
[Laughter]
anyway
all right you're a black belt for real
yeah that's crazy yeah why i mean
because i just didn't you never
do kicks
i never showed you my kicks i don't know
like you don't ever say like how you
doing you know you never like try to do
no i don't bring it out i don't like
building what though taekwondo oh really
yeah wow
but i'm not i don't think i remember how
to do anything i used to be really good
and i used to go to competitions and spa
and stuff but then i wanted to quit and
he said you can't quit until you at
least get your black belt and i got my
black belt and then the day after i quit
wow forced her to get a black brother
but she would i would go to the
tournaments with her and she didn't like
she doesn't like the violence and she
said it is weird it is weird hitting
somebody well she broke uh
in competition
much bigger people's uh guys legs
and they would and then she would you
broke people's legs and a nose and uh
arm you broke someone's leg
leg shin
wow yeah no she was in
you know on agt this year they have
those uh international taekwondo things
she used to do that like fly in the air
and
kick wood and
wow well i mean the wood thing that's
like you know i mean i don't know what
those wood those wood is it's they're
like made out of
you know it's kind of [ __ ] yeah no
it's not yeah it's super no guys it's
like two by fours speaking of agt you're
also going to start your residency yeah
at the luxor yeah and you're going to be
the host of the agt luxor show yeah it's
pretty cool that's really cool you're
going to move to vegas yeah i'm moving
to vegas
[Music]
you